c'est dire et dire que certains qui ne
nous connaissent pas bien pense que nous
n'avons pas le sens de l'accueil
tu vois à licola l'accueil formidable
des gens du nord pas de calais picardie
ils sont là pour te montrer leur chaleur
locaux big alité et aussi leur sens de
l'accueil
je veux ce soir pour suivre le fil le
fil d'une campagne qui ne s'arrête pas
et qui ne s'arrêtera pas dans les trois
mois qui viennent et après l'élection
celles et ceux qui croient en moi qui me
suivent qui m'entourent nos qu'un
objectif remettre cette région au
travail et redonner tout son sens à la
valeur du travail en 2007 nicolas
en 2007 nous avons porté cette valeur
cette valeur en 2007 c'est celle qui
nous a permis notamment de mettre en
avant les heures supplémentaires
défiscalisées de permettre à des
millions de français qui symbolisait la
valeur travail et qui ne prenait le
travail de personne d'autre tout
simplement de gagner plus parce qu'il
travaillait plus ce sont les socialistes
et françois hollande qui ont affaibli la
valeur travail en volant le produit des
heures supplémentaires défiscalisées aux
français la valeur travail nicolas c'est
quand j'ai porté avec toi la mise en
place du service minimum dans les
transports
parce que celles et ceux qui ont besoin
des transports pour aller travailler
ce qui symbolise la valeur travail en
avait assez d'être pris en otage par une
poignée qui eux cette poignée la
méprisait la valeur travail
quand nous avons mis en place le service
minimum dans les transports nous les
avons obligé c'est vrai à se déclarer
quand il faisait grève et nous avons mis
en place ce principe très simple si vous
faites grêve vous ne travaillez pas vous
ne travaillez pas vous n'êtes pas payé
voilà ce qu'il y a dans la loi sur le
service minimum
c'est la valeur travail alors
aujourd'hui je suis toujours dans la
même logique parce que notre région
notre grande région comme notre pays
comme notre jeunesse mon cher daniel ne
s'en sortira que par le travail et nous
savons tous les ravages dans cette
région plus qu'ailleurs de l'assistanat
l'assistanat est une prison l'assistanat
et or rien n'est jamais une solution
alors il faut vous soyez tous des
militants convaincus de ce que la
restauration de la valeur travail sera
aussi la solution aux problèmes de notre
région
la valeur travail porter la valeur
travail parce que je veux être plus
précis c'est avant tout penser à celles
et ceux qui travaillent et qui ont
travaillé qui sont en général toujours
les oubliées de la politique sauf sauf
sauf au moment de payer les impôts parce
que les catégories populaires et les
classes moyennes savent qu'elles ne sont
jamais oubliés notamment par le pouvoir
socialiste quand il s'agit de penser aux
impôts et je dénonce l'escroquerie
intellectuelle qui consiste aujourd'hui
à nous faire croire que l'on va en
exonérant des français de l'impôt sur le
revenu alléger leurs charges
il y a deux choses se sont donc moins de
français qui paieront l'impôt sur le
revenu et encore une fois ce sont les
classes moyennes qui symbolise la valeur
travail qui vont payer davantage et
surtout surtout jamais françois hollande
ne rendra aux français ce qui leur a
pris et volé depuis 2012
la valeur travail c'est aussi c'est
aussi penser à celles et ceux qui
donnent du travail
et si l'on me dit que je suis du côté
des employeurs j'accepte cette
caricature facile parce que ce ne sont
pas les hommes et les femmes politiques
qui donnent du travail qui crée le
travail ce sont les entrepreneurs
arrêtons de regarder de travers les
entrepreneurs comprenons qu on a besoin
d'eux quelle que soit la taille de
l'entreprise
il donne du travail ils créent de la
richesse et nous voulons tout simplement
dans cette région mettre en place un
projet très simple inspiré des
rencontres sur le terrain où les chefs
d'entreprise nous disent à la limite on
ne veut pas d'argent veut pas de
subventions on veut pas dead mais si
vous pouviez tout simplement arrêter de
nous mettre des bâtons dans les roues
et quand on réussit cessé de nous faire
les postes voilà tout simplement le
projet que je veux pour notre grande
région
et puis ensuite il y à celles et ceux
qui sont sans travail aujourd'hui et
parmi ceux-là je le vis la très grande
majorité plus qu'une majorité sait bien
qu'il faut retrouver un emploi mais cela
aujourd'hui ne sont pas toujours bien
accompagné
cela vous dise quand on est motivé quant
au fait une formation dans la région
il faut l'attendre six mois huit mois
parfois plus quand il ya des chefs
d'entreprise qui vous disent que depuis
un an il cherche lui salariés c'était le
cas à dunkerque encore on me le disait
et qu'on n'arrive pas à voir quelqu'un
qui nous présente des demandeurs
d'emploi motivés et la formation qui va
avec
sans être révolutionnaire sans avoir de
baguette magique
il sera tout simplement possible de
répondre à cette équation qui semble
insoluble
plus de 500 mille demandeurs d'emploi
dans notre région 132 mille offres
d'emploi qui ne trouvent pas preneur
voilà déjà comment on n'effacera pas le
chômage mais on permettra de ramener
vers le travail celles et ceux qui
servent vraiment un travail c'est à eux
que je veux m'adresser en priorité
de la même façon vous voulez éviter le
chômage aux jeunes alors fait clairement
le choix de l'apprentissage
tout le monde est d'accord sur
l'apprentissage mais il faut en faire
une priorité et comme la région
n'augmentera pas les impôts
il est évident qu'il faudra cessé
d'arroser le sable de faire plaisir à
tout le monde et de faire un choix très
clair
plutôt que de mettre de l'argent sur les
emplois aidés vous savez ces emplois qui
tant qu ils sont aidés sont là le jour
ils ne sont plus aidés ces emplois
conduisent au chômage je préfère
résolument faire le choix de
l'apprentissage pour sortir nos jeunes
du chômage
je veux être encore plus précis il y en
a aussi qui pensent que l'on peut s'en
sortir sans travailler alors même qu'il
pourrait travailler cela je veux leur
dire très clairement
alors que vous pouvez travailler vous ne
saisissez pas la chance qui vous sera
tendue si vous ne saisissez pas cette
chance je le dis très clairement
car je ne veux pas plaire à tout le
monde si vous ne voulez pas travailler
alors que vous le pouvez
je m'appelle xavier bertrand surtout ne
votez pas pour moi je ne suis pas le bon
candidat
celles et ceux
celles et ceux qui voudront rester dans
l'assistanat feront le choix du front
national qui exploite l'assistanat qui
ne sortira jamais la région de
l'assistanat
le front national a besoin des problèmes
pour être là le jour où il n'y a plus de
problème il n'y a plus de front national
je veux avec mes amis apporter des
solutions aux problèmes que nous
rencontrons il y a ceux qui veulent
laisser la région dans les problèmes
alors vous savez très clairement parce
que ça se jouera entre la fille de
jean-marie le pen et nous quels sont
ceux qui peuvent réellement sortir notre
région du déclin qu'elle connaît j'ai
parlé du travail
mais nicolas dans la région comme pour
notre pays les gens nous disent deux
choses il me dit monsieur ce qu'il faut
dans notre région c'est du boulot et de
l'autorité il faut du travail et de la
sécurité
les deux ensemble je ne dis pas que si
nous réussissons là dessus nous aurons
réglé tous les problèmes mais je sais
que notre région comme notre pays alors
se porteront bien mieux alors certains
s'étonnent que dans cette campagne je
parle de sécurité que je dénonce
l'impunité de celles et ceux qui ont
pris en otage des milliers
d'automobilistes sur l'autoroute un même
si ceux ci ne représentent pas toute la
communauté des gens du voyage
ils doivent répondre de leurs actes
les dégâts commis doivent être
remboursés pas par la collectivité pas
par la majorité silencieuse pas par les
braves gens mais tout simplement par
celles et ceux qui ont fait ce blocage
et qui ont montré que l'état quand il ne
voulait plus assurer leurs droits et
public 1 était un état qui démissionnait
nous avons besoin d'ordre républicain et
certainement pas d'impunité
alors oui oui oui je parlerai aussi de
sécurité dans cette région et je
voudrais renforcer également la sécurité
dans ce qui est de la compétence de la
région les transports parce que dans les
transports je crois au renforcement de
la présence policière je veux une police
des transports dans la région créée à
l'initiative de la région
je crois aussi à la vidéo surveillance
qui ne dérange pas les braves gens qui
les arrange tous ceux qui ont quelque
chose à se reprocher vous n'avez rien à
vous reprocher alors vous n'avez rien à
reprocher à la vidéosurveillance je
mettrai en place la vidéosurveillance
dans les gares
c'est de la compétence de la région
aussi et je ne fermeraient pas les yeux
je ne fermeraient pas les yeux sur les
raquettes ou les trafics de drogue qu'il
peut y avoir dans certains de nos
établissements scolaires
je mettrai en place tout un plan de
prévention mais aussi un plan d'action
pour lutter contre les ravages de la
drogue également dans notre région je ne
fermeraient pas les yeux sur le tel
fléau mais la sécurité c'est aussi la
sécurité partout sur le territoire et
vous me permettrez je n'avais pas eu
cette intention mais je leur ai donné la
parole à quelqu'un quelques instants
quelques instants parce qu'il ya un
endroit sur notre territoire dont on
parle beaucoup c'est calais
kaleme il y a beaucoup de symboles au
travers de calais je peux parler de
calais j'ai parlé fort paraît-il de
calais sur calais pendant l'été mais je
voudrais rendre hommage à quelqu'un que
j'ai appris à davantage connaître dans
cette campagne et qui parlera de calais
mieux que moi j'aurais donné la parole
quelques instants à la maire de calais à
cette mère courage que natacha bouchart
mes chers amis mes chers amis merci
merci d'abord de tous vos soutiens de
tous vos soutiens qui me vont
directement au coeur que ce soit par
téléphone par mail par facebook par tout
simplement des messages d'amitié des
petits mots très clairement qu'elle est
depuis près de 20 ans est dans une
situation difficile compliqué sangatte à
fermer merci merci nicolas pour ce
moment fort qui a été soutenue par tous
les élus quelle que soit leur
sensibilité
mais les choses ont changé et
aujourd'hui à nouveau nous nous
retrouvons avec 3500 réfugiés migrants
nous ne savons pas quel est exactement
leur statut je dirais simplement parce
que je ne suis pas là pour prendre la
parole
xavier merci pour ces quelques messages
que je peux passer c'est que sans la
fermeté sans la fermeté nous ne pouvons
pas faire de l'humanité c'est impossible
nous devons
nous devons passer ce message très fort
que pour aider des réfugiés il faut
impérativement à côté la même dose de
fermeté et aujourd'hui à calais et je
pense dans l'état français tout entier
cette fermeté n'existe plus et que nous
sommes un peu nous comme une zone de non
droit où il y a une espèce de
discrimination positive ou nos
concitoyens ne sont pas défendus dans
les mêmes valeurs qui doivent être les
nôtres à côté de réfugiés oui bien sûr
qu'ils doivent être protégés pour
certains parce que dans les 3500 on ne
sait pas clairement quelle est la
comptabilité des réfugiés politiques de
ceux qui ne sont pas calculés de ceux
qui on a pu passer
ils sont pas tombés du ciel ils ont bien
passé les différentes étapes les
frontières donc à laisser le
dysfonctionnement le dysfonctionnement
de l'europe
le dysfonctionnement des règles qui ne
sont pas mises en place
le dysfonctionnement de ce que la
sécurité l'ordre la loi et la justice ne
sont pas appliquées dans notre pays donc
je dirai simplement je suis je suis à
100% les propositions de nicolas sarkozy
je les suis et je les accompagne
mais vous devez comprendre vous devez
comprendre que dans notre situation je
suis dans l'obligation de demander
l'ouverture d'un centre parce que je
préfère que 3500 personnes aujourd'hui
certainement 4000 ou 5000 demain soit
encadré dans un lieu qui permettent à
mes concitoyens de pouvoir avoir une
tranquillité de vie aux minima même si
déjà nous subissons les dégradations
merci nicolas on tombe sur toi et on
attend tu reviennes
beaucoup d'hommes et de femmes
politiques peuvent se ressembler mais ce
qui fait parfois la différence c'est le
courage elle est courageuse mais tu as à
bouchard merci de ce courage
aujourd'hui c'est vrai aujourd'hui je
regarde calais je prends le problème de
calais comme s'ils habitaient calais élu
à la tête de la région
je devrais faire comme un maire dans sa
ville quel que soit l'endroit où ils
habitent chacun des problèmes dans sa
ville est aussi le sien c'est cela ma
responsabilité et je ne lâcherai pas ce
dossier de calais tant que nous n'aurons
pas réussi à régler le problème des
calaisiens dans ce cas dit natacha je
suis allé avec elle dans le centre ferry
qui étaient ouverts quelques heures par
jour par la mairie pour soulager la
population
celui qui va dans ce centre s'il ne voit
pas l'humanité
il est aveugle où il ne veut pas voir
mais en contrepartie syli à ce centre
les calaisiens doivent aspirer à la
tranquillité et à la sécurité ne pas
être importuné sur le parking de
l'hypermarché quand on va faire ses
courses de faire en sorte aussi que les
décisions de justice pour expulser ceux
qui squattent devant une église
saint-pierre saint-paul cela soit
expulsé et s'il y a bien évidemment de
l'humanité la fermeté qui ne dépend pas
des anglais cette fois ci cette fermeté
qui ne dépend pas des européens
cette fermeté elle ne dépend que de
l'état que de l'état français c'est à
manuel valls 7 à bernard cazeneuve de
faire appliquer les décisions de justice
ou celles et ceux qui tous les soirs
essaye de rentrer dans le tunnel au
péril de leur vie
cela ne doivent pas être déplacé de 350
mètres cela parce qu'il viole la loi au
péril de leur vie
ceux là doivent être expulsés du
territoire français ça ça ne dépend que
du gouvernement français et nous leur
demandons de le faire de ne pas attendre
de mettre en place une les aspects une
nouvelle zone policière pour renforcer
les effectifs dans leur demande de
comprendre les problèmes des calaisiens
et de comprendre aussi que calais à des
projets que calais comme toute cette
région en a marre qu'on parle de calais
uniquement avec de ces problèmes il faut
de la volonté y en a fallu si je ne me
trompe pas voilà de nombreuses années
nicolas tu as su faire preuve de cette
volonté
il faut aujourd'hui le même courage elle
même volonté c'est comme cela que nous
serons résoudre même si c'est pas facile
les problèmes de calais alors nous
savons aussi que beaucoup quittent leur
pays la situation économique
mais il ya aussi la situation de guerre
beaucoup beaucoup se reconnaissent dans
des idées que nous avons pu exprimer
cette semaine soit encore à la
télévision le problème est simple tant
que l'on s'évertuera à penser que seuls
les conséquences sont importantes
on ne réussira à rien faire cette
politique des quotas qui nous est
imposée aujourd'hui par bruxelles ne
règlera en rien les problèmes que nous
rencontrons aujourd'hui car dans
quelques semaines on nous dira que le
nombre de réfugiés accueillis ne suffit
pas quand on sait qu'il ya deux millions
de personnes qui fuient leur pays en
syrie on nous dira qu'il faut faire
davantage et on aura alors menti aux
français quand un premier ministre nous
sommes là quelques semaines que cette
politique n'avait pas de sens et
qu'aujourd'hui on l'appliquent sous la
pression eh bien je suis désolé ce
qu'ils disent à mantes et expose notre
pays a de véritables problèmes plus
importants encore ce qu'il nous faut
c'est tout simplement comprendre que
tant qu'on n'aura pas éradiqué dèche
nombre de ces malheureux quitteront leur
pays
on oublie bien souvent on oublie bien
souvent que ça n'est pas voilà cinq
siècles les images que l'on voit c'est
maintenant c'est malheureux qui dans une
cage sont brûlés vifs d'autres sont
égorgés décapité et les femmes et les
enfants deviennent des esclaves
sexuelles certains pourraient se dire
mais c'est eux là bas non ce sont les
mêmes qui endoctrinent qui apprennent le
djihad qui armé qui financent celles et
ceux qui nous ont fait tant de mal sur
notre territoire et qui continueront
tant qu'ils ne nous exterminons pas on
peut dire que je suis un va-t-en-guerre
on peut dire que je suis pour une guerre
totale eh bien oui eux pratiquent à
notre égard une guerre totale nous
devons pratiquer une guerre totale pour
éliminer dice
je n'ai pas envie je n'ai pas envie je
n'ai pas envie que mes enfants
grandissent en ayant peur je n'ai pas
envie que loïc grandissent en baissant
la tête ça n'est pas la vocation du
peuple français de baisser la tête face
au terrorisme
et quand on oppose pas la fermeté et la
générosité
parce que bien souvent et bien longtemps
la politique la république n'ont pas été
assez généreuse envers nos malheureux il
a fallu vous prenez la question
notamment des personnes handicapées les
grandes lois de 75 et 2005 il a fallu
l'action tel que soit la crise après
2007 où nous avons augmenté
l'allocation d'adulte handicapé de 25 %
et aussi le minimum vieillesse de 25%
même si ça n'était pas facile
nous avons voulu être au rendez-vous de
cette générosité alors qu'on ne nous
fasse pas à nous le procès du manque
d'humanité et de générosité
mais il est temps aussi que la
république se soucie de tous ces
malheureux c'est le message que nous
envoie les gens de bon sens pour
conclure du travail et de l'autorité
voilà ce qu'il faut et dans notre pays
aussi et d'ailleurs on voit tout le mal
qu'elle et ses côtés françois hollande
tout le mal qu à cause et christiane
taubira et il faudra je pense à l'avenir
à l'avenir pour éviter pour éviter
qu'on ait le sentiment que quand les
policiers font leur travail ce qu'ils
arrêtent sont bien souvent relâchés
je pense qu'il nous faudra un seul
effort ministère de l'autorité un
ministère de l'autorité qui regroupe en
même temps l'ancien ministère de
l'intérieur et l'ancien ministère de la
justice parce que si on croit l'autorité
on met tous les moyens pour qu'il n'y en
ait pas qui tire à hue pendant que les
autres tirent à bien il faut ce
ministère de l'autorité et certainement
pas avec une madame taubira sa tête
nous voulons gagner cette région ce qui
est vrai pour cette région est vrai pour
la nation il nous faut tout d'abord être
rassemblées nous sommes ici et je sais
tous les efforts je te le disais tout à
l'heure que tu mènes aussi à la tête de
notre famille pour qu'elles soient
rassemblées
elle en avait bien besoin je le dis
aussi à celles et ceux qui ont des
ambitions et vous savez que en la
matière je peux aussi parler pour moi
mais avant les élections primaires il ya
des régionales et en ce qui me concerne
l'enjeu n'est pas de gagner mais de
réussir à la tête de la région pour
savoir la sortir de son déclin ça sera
aussi l'enjeu de 2017 ne pas seulement
gagner mais réussir ne pas avoir peur de
déplaire avant mais en disant
précisément ce que l'on fera et répondre
aussi à la question comment comment vous
ferez ça veut dire être précis ça veut
dire c'est comme je lé fais tout à
l'heure ne pas chercher à chercher à se
faire apprécier embrasser aimé par tout
le monde
mais faire part de sa liberté de penser
sa liberté de ton et donc la liberté
d'action ici dans cette région
nous sommes unis et rassemblés je vous
remercie tous les parlementaires de
cette région qui jouent le jeu à 200%
je remercie aussi celui qui est mon
directeur de campagne métier plus que ça
et qui accepte de me rejoindre et de
participer à cette formidable aventure
c'est gérald darmanin qui nous a des
organes elle parce qu'il aime sa ville
parce qu'il aime sa région et il est
comme moi y sera pas les choses à moitié
je les remercie toutes et tous d'avoir
compris que nous avions besoin de cette
alliance avec les centristes avec cpnt
mais qu'aussi le devions associés aux
partis politiques des acteurs qui
s'étaient éloignés de la politique et
qui avait envie de nous rejoindre
oui je fais le choix dans cette région
de faire confiance aux agriculteurs je
fais le choix de faire confiance aux
chasseurs et ça nous permettra aussi le
tourner la page dans cette région des
malheurs et des dégâts qu'ont causé les
verts ces écologistes intégristes que
sont les verts dans cette région si je
gagne les verts dehors de cette région
je dirais dans toute cette campagne 7 9
ans au risque de déplaire
je mènerai cette campagne avec vous et
pour vous je fais campagne contre le
déclin ceux qui ont causé le déclin le
parti socialiste et celles et ceux qui
exploitent déclamer qui rendrait
définitif c'est le front national il n'y
a que nous il n'y a que nous qui sommes
aujourd'hui capables d'entendre le
désarroi de celles et ceux qui ne
viennent plus aux réunions publiques de
celles et ceux qui ne veulent plus voter
c'est eux qu'il faut convaincre et je
vous demande mes amis quand vous serait
reparti du touquet de cette formidable
ville daniel du touquet d'aller partout
et de leur dire qu'ils écoutent ce que
nous avons à leur dire qu'ils viennent
aux réunions
il me pose des questions comme nous le
faisons tous les soirs et il voit
clairement qui est sincère qui sera le
porte parole des six millions
d'habitants du nord pas de calais
picardie
pendant les années qui viennent je veux
remettre cette région au travail alors
si vous voulez m'aider au travail